[موسيقى]
هي اكثر طائره متعدده لاستخدامات متوفره
حاليا وهي تستجيب لتشكيله واسعه من
احتياجات القرن الحادي والعشرين للقوات
الجويه العالميه والمنظمات الاخرى
وبامكانها تنفيذ ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه انواع
من الواجبات الهجوميه والمهمات
الاستراتيجيه مباشره الى موقع العمليات
[موسيقى]
فهي الحل المثالي لانزال الحمولات من
المرتفعات المتدنيه وانزال الجنود من
الارتفاعات العاليه والمنخفضه مثلا 40 الف
قدم للقوات الخاصه وبالاضافه الى ذلك وكما
تعرفون فان طائره اي 4 ام حلقت بارتفاعات
منخفضه خلال ظروف مناخيه محوريه لانها كما
نعرف صممت لتكون منخفضه وصعبه الكشف عنها
[موسيقى]
نرى طائره اي 4 ام بكل فخر وهي تعمل كقوه
من اجل الخير في الحرب ضد كوفيد 19 واجلاء
المدنيين الافغان من كابول او لايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه في باكستان هذه مجرد
امثله عن خدمات طائره اي 4 ام لمجتمعاتنا
[موسيقى]